pues vamos a hablar francamente acerca
de las sucesiones geométricas las
sucesiones geométricas y una sucesión
geométrica se ve más o menos decir
tenemos un término inicial
y después lo que va a pasar es que para
encontrar el siguiente término a este
término inicial lo vamos a multiplicar
por una razón entonces me quedaría
el siguiente término sería a por rm el
siguiente término hay que multiplicarlo
otra vez por la razón o sea me quedaría
a por r cuadrada a por r por r pues es
lo mismo que a poner de cuadrada déjenme
ponerlo con el mismo color
cuadrada y después si lo sigo
multiplicando por r el tercer término me
va a quedar a r cúbica y etcétera
fíjense que estoy poniendo puntitos y
esto significa que es una sucesión
infinita también tenemos aquí sucesiones
infinitas y bueno de hecho esta sucesión
la puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
puede escribir como la sucesión a zubin
cn desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito
recuerden una asociación infinita con y
ahora sí vamos a encontrar las reglas de
asociación
es igual al primer término am que
multiplica a quien y fíjate aquí este
término am es lo mismo que tener a por
él a 0 porque recuerda que todo el
número elevado a la 0 es 1 por a ese ere
y esto lo pongo porque aquí me va a
quedar a por él a 0 a por él a 1 a poder
de la 2a poder de la 3 etcétera dicho de
otra manera el término n lo encontramos
como a por r elevado a la n 1 fíjate en
el término uno es el acero en el término
2s de la 1 en el término 3 r elevado a
la 2 etcétera por lo tanto es a por r a
la n 1 o bueno también lo podemos
escribir de manera recursiva como las
sucesiones aritméticas tendríamos la
sucesión de desde n igual a 1 es
infinito con y bueno primero el término
inicial va a ser am a1 es igual
a esto se le pone que es para n igual a
1 solamente para n igual a 1 y después
para todas en el mayor o igual a 2 es
más déjeme escribirlo aquí este es un
término inicial es que suena un poco
redundante todo esto es decir escribirlo
así pero bueno
quiero poner en forma recursiva ya tengo
que mi primer término am y después me
termino n es lo mismo que el término
anterior es decir me terminó a n menos 1
x hereda de cuenta que lo único que
estaba haciendo era multiplicar por r
por r
por r por r y esto para n mayor o igual
a 2 por lo tanto así construyó una
sucesión geométrica y ya que tenemos las
dos definiciones mi definición de forma
explícita y mi definición de forma
recursiva a ver creo que está muy
abstracto hasta aquí vamos a verlo con
un ejemplo tengo la sucesión n desde n
igual a 1 está infinito con esta
siguiente regla de asociación a n va a
ser igual a 20 vamos a poner un numerito
aquí 20 que multiplica a quien se me
ocurren aquí se me ocurre tiene que
multiplicar una razón cuantas veces
queramos entonces vamos a decir que la
razón es un medio y bueno esto es
elevado a la en el -1 por la misma razón
que acabamos de decir aquí arriba
entonces si ya tengo esta definición de
esta sucesión cuáles son los términos de
esta sucesión pues vamos a ver el primer
término me va a quedar 20 lo único que
estoy haciendo sustituyendo a n por uno
y uno
el acero es uno por veinte me queda 20
ahora en mi segundo término voy a
sustituir a n por 2 me queda dos menos
11 y 20 por un medio me queda 10 lo
único que estamos haciendo es
multiplicando por un medio es decir
sacando la mitad me quedaría 55 medios
la mitad de cinco medios que son cinco
cuartos etcétera lo único que estoy
haciendo para pasar del siguiente
término el siguiente término es
multiplicando por un medio la definición
de una sucesión geométrica perfecto
parece ser que va quedando un poco mejor
a ver ahora viene la segunda pregunta yo
tengo la sucesión 12
qué sigue qué es lo que quiero bueno a
esto lo voy a poner después 24 y después
120 y después puntitos muy bien ya tengo
esta sucesión es acaso esta sucesión una
sucesión geométrica pues es la pregunta
que quiero responder entonces de aquí
para acá
multiplicamos por dos de aquí para acá
multiplicamos por tres de aquí para acá
multiplicamos por cuatro te das cuenta
estamos multiplicando por el siguiente
número y después por cinco de 24 para
120 multiplicamos por 5 y justo en ese
momento es cuando dices no está no es
una asociación geométrica sin embargo
vamos a seguir trabajando la para ver a
qué llegamos tenemos un primer término
inicial y después tenemos que el segundo
término es dos veces am dos veces am el
tercer término era tres por dos por am
es decir el tercer término lo sacamos
multiplicando el segundo término por
tres el término 4 sacamos multiplicando
el tercer término por 4 me quedaría 4
por 3 por 2 por am
y qué pasa con esta sucesión esta
obsesión está un poco rara te das cuenta
vamos a ver si la podemos definir
me quedaría la sucesión de los genes
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito con la
siguiente regla de asociación y que
regla la sucesión tienen bueno en este
caso en el caso original
empezamos en 1 es decir a vale 1 por lo
tanto tenemos 1 por 2 después por 3
después por 4 esto no te suena un poco
como a la función factorial 1 2 por 1 3
por 2 por 1 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 5 por 4
por 3 por 2 x 1 etcétera es decir estos
ni más ni menos que lo que conocemos
como la función factorial lo cual no es
una sucesión geométrica recuerda pero ya
tenemos una forma de definirlo y es más
podemos escribir esta sucesión con una
sucesión a recursiva recuerda que no
siempre o no forzosamente se pueden
escribir como una forma recursiva sin
embargo vamos a intentarlo creo que si
sale tendríamos la sucesión de los genes
desde n igual a 1 hasta infinito hasta
y es otra vez lo mismo la sucesión de
los genes desde n igual a 1 hasta n
igual infinito con y vamos a ponerla de
forma recursiva a 1 el término inicial
es igual a 1 no es lo que teníamos ahora
como escribimos el término en el término
n es igual al término anterior n menos 1
ya esto lo multiplicamos por n
exactamente por ejemplo el término 3 es
lo mismo que el término 2 x 3 etcétera y
ya encontramos una segunda forma de
definirla